with almost every one of these questions
as soon as you can let's start by
drawing a graph what makes you think
graph when you look at this well you've
got an equation over here it's just a
straight line you've got an equation
over here to absolute values can be one
of those weird bouncy curves right when
you're being asked to solve this you're
being asked to find where is it that
these two intersect that's that's all an
equation like this means okay so if I
would you draw and all you need it's
multiple choice I'm looking for one
market right so I don't even need a
beautiful graph I just need a rough one
right let's have a look how what this
will look like okay three X plus two
three X plus two so we know it's gonna
be fairly steep was the to tell you the
to tells you the y-intercept so sin it's
been shifted vertically a little bit so
I'm just gonna do a rough drawing of
that okay now I know this is - what's
this Y very this x value going to be
think about it it's obviously going to
be negative over there on the left-hand
side if you were solving for this equals
zero right this equals zero then you
would add sorry you would subtract two
from both sides and you would have
negative two on the left hand side you
divide by three so I think that's
negative two thirds are you okay with
that you can pop it in you can check
okay that's good what about this other
graph absolute value of 2x minus one
well we know what the absolute sorry we
know what 2x minus one
normally looks like the two tells you
it's steeper or less steep compared to
the other line steeper or less steep
it's less steep than that one right so
if I'm calling that gradient three maybe
I'll call that gradient two it's got a
minus one over this so this has not been
shifted up and shifted down okay so
therefore this is kind of what 2x minus
1 on its own would normally look like
okay but I don't have 2x minus 1 I have
the absolute value of 2x minus 1 so what
happens to this part over here when you
apply an absolute value to it this part
nothing happens to this section over
here do you agree because it's positive
the absolute value of something positive
is still positive okay but then when
you've got this section down here which
is negative the absolute value of this
is going to reflect upwards like so okay
are you happy with that now you're
looking for a point of intersection
immediately you can discount some of the
solutions that are provided to you in
this multiple choice question because if
I have a look
ABCD you tell me which of these I can
disregard I could disregard C which has
no solutions because no solutions
graphically would mean that they never
intersect but they clearly do which
other one can I disregard I can
disregard D now this takes a little more
thought why can't there be two solutions
like I know I don't have the whole graph
how do I know there isn't a solution
somewhere else
it's about the steepness right this is
why I asked you about that beginning
that's gonna fly off because of the fan
this is steeper than this right
so as these go on forever and ever
remember they're never going to come
back together at any point okay so
therefore I'm not going to get any
solutions on the right-hand side I'll
only get this one solution right here
okay now if this were like a proper
extended response question I would then
have to write some equations down and I
would have to find the solution
algebraically and so on okay but this is
multiple choice
so I now want you to have a look again C
and D we disregard it because they were
ridiculous based on this graph but if
you're looking a little carefully again
you can disregard a solution quite
quickly with no working out which one
can you disregard you can disregard a
because where is x equals negative 3
well that's negative 2/3 right there
yeah so that would be negative 1 that
makes negative 2 here negative 3 there
that's not where the solution is clearly
it's in this little spot here so I drew
a graph to be honest this would have
happened a lot faster it's just that
I've been talking it through with you so
you understand the thinking process but
I'm done no real computation involved B
okay the graph is where all of the logic
happens ok so you're not doing yourself
any favors if you like I can do this
with cases hooray it's a one more
question use the 1 mark method